this question combines demarvor's
theorem with some of our older
techniques
for handling trigonometric equations
that we need to solve
how did i know that i needed to model
the theorem for this question not just
that the whole exercise
is using this result but also when you
have a look at the question
like if this question was presented to
you in the middle of an exam it doesn't
have like a nice title over the top that
tells you what you need to use
you can see here that there's these
large multiples integer multiples of
angles that you can see
in the right hand side of this result
that i'm trying to prove
and even though i could use just regular
trigonometric expansions to deal
with what these are um demolition allows
me to get to them
relatively efficiently using you know
binomial expansions and all the rest
that we can connect with
our complex number knowledge so that's
what sort of signals to me that i'm
going to use demarcus theorem
i'm going to have to use it twice one
for the sine five theta term and then
one for the sine
three theta terms so there's going to be
a fair bit of working
here it's one of those long-haul
questions that we've seen
done before so we better get stuck into
it here's part a
by demarva's theorem you should always
quote demurra's theorem just like
pythagoras whenever you use it
the first thing i'm going to do is i'm
going to quote it for
uh you know raising a complex number cos
theta plus i sine theta to the power of
5.
now rather than put that result on the
left hand side i'm going to put it on
the right hand side
cos theta plus i sine theta to the power
of five
because i'm going to have to expand this
thing and it's going to become a little
bit obviously that's the main amount of
work i'm going to be doing on this
so then on the left hand side i'm just
going to have the result and
nothing's going to happen to it so it's
just going to stay put
okay so this is what de mars theorem
tells me for n equals 5.
now i need to do the the hard work of
expanding here on the right hand side
now when i think about the question you
can see that everything in
part a and part b has to do with science
right now that's what signals to you
when you think about
the polar form of a complex number that
i'm going to be focused on the imaginary
part
the real part here is going to be sort
of irrelevant to me so what i'm going to
do
as i have in the past is when i expand
this i'm not just going to put all six
terms
of this expansion just in in a row i'm
actually going to put
the real parts on one side and the
imaginary parts on the other side so
that just makes it easier for me
to separate them when i do my comparison
so
what's our first term going to be well
uh it's going to be
uh cos five to the power of theta
um and then i add my next one i'll put
it a little further along because i'm
going to need the space
i'm going to have to have the binomial
coefficient how many powers of cos
and how many powers of i sine theta i'm
going to have
so because i'm on the uh the fifth row
of
pascal's triangle my next coefficient
will be 5
i will have one fewer cos theta
and i'll have one more i sine theta and
so you can clearly see
this is what's going to give us the
imaginary component there
what's my next one well i'm going to put
it underneath here because i know in
advance because my
eyes keep multiplying i'm going to get a
real component for the next one
so the next binomial coefficient along
is 10 so
you get one fewer cos
one extra i sine
i clearly did not move this far over
enough that's better
and then i'm going to add the next one
so i'm going 1
5 10 i'm in the middle so 10
cos squared theta i sine
theta all cubed i'm past halfway
in my binomial expansion so i'm back
down to five
i've got one cos left i've now got
four of these and then the last term the
remaining
binomial coefficient is just 1 and then
it's going to be i
sine theta to the power of 5. okay
now i'm about to do a comparison of the
imaginary parts on the left and right
hand side
but before i do that i need to sort of
clarify what's going
on that that these are indeed you know
it's not just because i can see them
and i know in advance what these are
going to expand out to be i need to show
that there's just a single factor of i
out the front which i can then do the
comparison with so
even though i could simplify these guys
too i'm actually not going to worry
about the real parts and simplifying
them because it's just extra mental
effort that
i don't need to expend because i'm not
going to compare the real parts of both
sides
when i have a look at these these three
terms
over on the right hand side that's a
really messy word right let's try that
again
when i look at these three terms over
here what i want to do is just
factor out the i so it's very clear that
these are imaginary so
here comes the first one it's just going
to be i outside of
cos the 4 theta and a single sine theta
what's the next one well let's have a
look i've got i cubed so
i squared out of that will become minus
and so
this plus is going to become a minus
there and then one lot
of the eyes is left over so i'll
factorize that i out
that leaves me with 10 cos squared theta
and then sine
cubed and then lastly down here i've got
i to power
5 so r to the power of 4 is just 1 by
definition
and so that leaves you with one of the
eyes left over so that's i
sine to the 5 theta equals 1. okay great
so what i've got now you can clearly see
if i drag this along
you can clearly see that these terms
here are all imaginary
so i've got this part over here
and so now i'm going to do my comparison
of imaginary parts so comparing
the imaginary parts
uh what am i going to get on the left
hand side i've got sine
5 theta and then on the right hand side
you can see i'm just going to have all
of those terms that i circled
in red just over here and so i'm just
going to grab them i'm just going to
copy them down except i don't need the
eyes so
that should do it
and however because i didn't get the
eyes i didn't get the
signs in between so that's a minus and
that's a plus okay so
here are the imaginary parts of the
left-hand side and the right-hand side
but you can see
that in order to use this when you have
a look back at the original results
there are no cosines here so i've got to
get rid of all of these cosines
somehow now thankfully because i've got
lots of things being squared
i can use the pythagorean identity sine
squared theta plus
cos squared theta equals 1. in order to
change all of these
cos squareds out for sine squareds i'm
going to
subtract that from both sides so this
result is what i'm going to use
but i do notice that in fact i don't
just have a cos squared
on the left hand side here i also have a
close to our 4
here so in order to use that if i square
the left hand side i'd have to square
the right hand side as well
so i'm going to use both of these
results and do this simplification
all right what do we get well in the
first distance i've got 5
times here's my substitution for cos to
the 4
theta i'm going to use this so it's
going to look like 1 minus sine
squared theta squared and then it's
multiplied by
sine theta so that's what i'm getting
from the first term
i'll leave that on its own line because
it's going to become quite messy in a
second
then i get this guy 1 minus 10
let's see here so this is 1 minus sine
squared theta and then it's multiplied
by sine cubed
theta and then i think this plus sign
the 5 theta will fit onto this line just
fine
okay so i have to do some expansion here
you do have to take care
um that you don't get any terms a stray
so i'm going to have the 5
sine theta out the front from here and
here
and now i've got to do the work of
expanding this 1 minus sine squared
squared so let's go ahead and do that
i've got 1 minus 2
sine squared and then i'm going to add
sine to the power of
4 theta that looks okay
and then you can see here i'm going to
get on the next line
minus 10 this sine cubed out the front
is going to multiply 1 minus sine
squared i'm going to do all my
expansions
in one hit okay
so far so good what does this lend us
with well let's take
these two sets of brackets here and
expand both of them
taking care with my coefficients and my
signs 5 sine theta times 1 is just 5
sine theta
minus 10 sine looks like that's going to
be cubed
and then i'm going to add 5 sine to the
power of 5
theta okay so far so good i want to
watch out here because there's a double
negative that i'm going to have to
expand
this first one is just multiplied by 1
so it's the same and then i'm going to
add 10 sine to the power of 5
theta again that's where i'm getting
this and this term from
and then you've got the plus sine to the
power of five theta
hanging out on the end okay things are
tracking along okay i've got to collect
like terms obviously because now i've
expanded everything out
so let's have a look there seems to be
only this one solitary sine theta term
out the front but then there's a whole
bunch of other ones that can simplify
so if you have a look at this sine cubed
term
and then there's another sine cubed term
and then here comes our sign of the five
terms in here and
here all right so let's have a go at
this 5
sine theta out the front and then let's
do this in
red minus 10 minus 10 that looks like
it's a minus 20.
and then when you have a look at our
sign to power five terms
um you can see i've got uh five here
10 there and uh one there along the end
so that looks like
plus 16 sine to the power of five
okay how does everything look is it all
checking
out i'm looking at all my signs
i think i am i think i'm happy with that
okay so
that is our result for sine of 5
theta so that's good that's progress you
can see that if i go back to my
original question i've got sine of 5
theta it's just in terms of sines
this 16 and the sine to the power 5
theta
that seems to have appeared over here so
that's that's promising
but i'm certainly not all the way there
right you can see that i've i've only
dealt with
this part of it and i haven't done dealt
with the sign three theta okay